David
we will be revealing the predictions by
our experts later today but for now it's
all on Wesley so he starts with the
English Simon once again
stop playing out there and this is very
traditional English and we saw this uh
what I remember about this position and
uh the world championships in I think it
was 86 in Seville Casper of karpov they
played this E5 reverse to sit in many
times but this is now one of the more
main lines and this night retreat has
become quite a trendy move I think Grizz
Chuck uh first played it and it really
is just a reverse Sicilian
um and it's a good Dragon for white but
a good Dragon may still be a bad dragon
in some cases this position is actually
a very fun one to play you've got the
bishop kind of like the Catalan Bishop
David you've got a rook coming to C1 for
example white pushes the pawn forward it
takes away this Square from uh White's
Bishop but yeah it feels like Magnus
just playing mind games here and the
dragon is signified by this bishop
coming out to G2 and just to show the
idea we call it a reverse Sicilian
because essentially uh let's backtrack
the hallway very quickly here
essentially the dragon or a very similar
let's go for the accelerated Dragon here
for a similar position would be this one
branching from the Sicilian where here
after Bishop to G7 white could for
example bring the Knight back and we
would see something very similar to the
game just with reverse colors so white
is essentially upper Tempo and one move
in chess it's psychologically affects
them to the point where they're using
maybe three unnecessary minutes right
Wesley down on the clock again so I
wanna I wanna again just call out the
while I do like Wesley's position I
think he has a good chance to rebound
and maybe level this thing at least as
far as the first few moves I still just
you have to applaud Magnus Carlson and
reminds me of what Fabiano caruana said
about him which is again people
underestimate how well you have to know
openings to look like you're avoiding
openings the bishop goes to D6 instead
of E7 this is not a typical structure
for for how black plays these reverse
dragons yet he's in a playable position
and guess what he made his opponent burn
three and a half minutes on the clock so
this is the kind of stuff he does in
Rapid chess and it often pays off is it
the the quite weird moves there goes
another poor move and um it's it's kind
of yeah this is this is a modern very
modern way of facing White's uh White's
position here and there's generally
going to be pressure on the queen side
here with that Rook move uh against
Black's Queen side yeah and uh it does
kind of reflect how Magnus works on
chess getting a glimpse of the genius of
Magnus Carlton here and his opening
approach and a strategy there's a
positional threat on the board and again
we can draw on that pool of knowledge we
have from other openings here the
Sicilian and In the Sicilian with
reverse colors we talk about an exchange
sacrifice and it's a very thematic one I
think Wesley's in a really great spot um
to rebound here and again that would be
the drama we want so we'll see if it's
the drama we get either way uh Wesley's
calculating this right now I think
pushing the pawn might be the key
because you can't take F6 oh okay I
thought you can't take F6 because white
black will take F3 with tempo right okay
so that was right he's just covering his
face like this very relaxed look at that
head to the side especially when you go
to the right hand side you're recalling
the good moment moments in your life but
it is it's it's cool right I mean I like
it I like the long hair would you reckon
Dave I want to get back to the position
because the part on E5 has been decking
and it feels like LPD or loose pieces
drop off so many tactics what's going on
here he has to give up some material now
it's just how to do it he he he shook
his head while we were distracted
um when he went for it now he does
choose to sack the exchange by Bishop C7
he could have also played Brook takes C6
and the D6 square is available
for the for the bishop of the night long
term the Magnus doesn't go for it
instead he hits the bishop on C7 based
on the movie plate or the fact that he
took so much time to do it because he's
still down four minutes on the clock and
sometimes the player is shaking their
head and we think it's because of the
last move and he and they're like yo bro
you gotta move faster just like wake up
you know shaking their own head so I
don't know I mean I think the position
is objectively playable more pure power
right they can control more squares and
at some point if white isn't accurate
when the time scramble ensues those
Rooks are going to get going right the
open files will will be available
and was that a mistake by Wesley sorry
Donnie yeah I don't know it's okay and
and uh and anyway so it's the Rooks are
there for a reason I think Wesley just
wants to really protect C5 with D4 next
okay undermine the vicious protection I
have no idea and it is getting a little
bit funky isn't it it's dancing around
creating some problems it's uh it's it's
not clear at all five in some situations
C4 D6 would be lovely but black gets the
moves as well and how do you defend C5
now the bishop comes in you stop Knight
F5 yeah it's it's very very tense
I was coming back to it and I think it's
yeah it's a nice idea and but we've
sorry
[Laughter]
yeah temporary peace sacrifice Magnus
gave up the Black Knight but just by
capturing pawns he was attacking there
just temporarily white tonight and
White's Bishop at the same time and
white couldn't save them both and uh
here we see still the same material and
balance at night and two pawns for a
rook but Danny called it the lines have
opened up the position is exploding and
for Rooks that is a good sign White's
night looks nice and pretty in the
center but blacks Rooks have access it's
technology General but you can't save
this piece anyway so he thought he had
to give it up for the pawn and yeah
let's just check out this position
Magnus is giving up a third one okay
it's just been captured he's going for
checkmate he's going to try and break
through on the back Rank and it's on the
board we're going to find out maybe that
night you mentioned has to jump back to
take control of that back rank C1 Square
Knight he do it but that runs into a
nasty check David black takes F1 you
take and you check the king's gonna run
to E2 and we're getting out if you made
a mistake I don't know Queen one looks
scary I don't know maybe yeah you go to
E4 he's gone with Harry the H1 and
uncharacteristically turns out to be a
bad move what uncharacteristically of
Harry the computer's just gone Haywire
how can H4 ever be a bad move steps
forward and starts running it's so calm
so calm away oh my words how can you do
that I mean that is computer chess isn't
it David look at what Magnus played he
didn't play the best movie it's a good
move we should mention I think this
showed up as uh one of the top moves but
uh yeah just to highlight here Magnus
could have won on the spot I think the
idea was actually just this check on H5
I think this would have been a really
nasty blow and if you're for example
forced to push your Pawn this white king
now is pretty much trapped and any check
on the second rank I'm not sure how you
get there maybe you go back and threaten
Checkmate this looks like it would have
been decisive but Magnus not going for
the Brute Force approach instead just
shuffling his King we call this a very
high class move just uh preempting any
checks from the White Queen he's just
waiting now how do you deal with the
threats right and we see he couldn't do
it accurately he plays Queen A4 which
helps Flex Advantage increase a little
bit this doesn't see it yet for sure the
best move okay he's played it I was
gonna say the best move is also the most
natural move but you called it Tanya the
follow-up is the key often players don't
blunder because of the first move it's
always the final follow-up and still
winning position here is it a check with
that black queen do you dive in now
maybe it's more effective now with
White's Queen unable to check the black
king he does dive in you're already
assignment I mean this is the simple way
isn't it I mean uh because I mean the
white king just looks you know even if
white can defend this somehow which I
don't think he can now you've got two
major pieces big pieces the biggest
pieces attacking a naked King you're
gonna have to maybe can you play this E4
move again he doesn't play it he's
trying to bring his pieces back this is
why he trained the puzzle Rush this is
why you train your puzzles so you can
work these things out uh quickly because
you do you check with the rook and you I
think this is the right way of doing it
because you forced the king into a more
exposed situation now I'm thinking do
you bring the queen over but you have to
calculate this right David I mean uh
okay wow by the way he's giving up the
F7 Pawn but it would be made if you go
for it it's just the Magna show today
isn't it seven seconds would you fight
on would you give up the queen for the
rook and try and set up a fortress with
the King Knight and porn he's gonna love
me oh and that's it wow Magnus Carlsen
with the black pieces delivers Checkmate
antiques his
second win and there he is what a
performance he's had today in his Grand
Final